how to solve a Rubik's Cube faster
advanced f2l techniques hi everyone I'm
Rob and welcome to my tutorial on how to
solve a Rubik's Cube faster over the
past year I've received numerous
requests for a tutorial outlining ways
you can improve your soft times on the
3x3 cube there are several ways you can
become faster and these improvements are
broken down into two main categories
physical and mental physical includes
the quality and speed of the cube itself
lubricating your cube and using finger
tricks instead of trying to turn each
face with your entire hand memorization
of various algorithms and also
understanding how the cube works in
general
are some of the mental improvements you
can make in this tutorial I would like
to go through the techniques and
algorithms for solving f2l or the first
two layers this will involve methods for
orienting positioning and joining the
bottom corners and the middle edges
together simultaneously although it will
take some time to train your brain to
learn these new optimized moves you will
find that with practice you should
become faster at solving the cube I do
highly recommend that you know the
beginner method and you can solve the
cube in around a minute and a half or
less before attempting these new
advanced techniques the cross as you
should already know is a relatively
intuitive step before completing f2l if
you're unsure of how to solve the cross
I recommend you first view my 3x3
beginner tutorial we're going to
consider the cross our starting point
for this tutorial please note I will be
using the white side as my down face and
the yellow side as my up face each of
the four white edges which make up this
cross must be matched to both colors
before continuing with f2l once you've
completed the bottom white cross you'll
notice there are various ways that the
bottom white corners and the middle
edges can be arranged on your cube the
corner in the edge might already be
solved like it is here it doesn't happen
very often but when it does you can
consider yourself lucky and move on a
more common case that occurs is one
where the corner and the edge are both
in the top layer in this case they are
at Jason or directly next to each other
but they can both be in the top layer
like this blue orange white corner and
the blue orange edge and be separate
another case that might occur is one
where
corner the white corner is somewhere on
the bottom layer in this case it happens
to be solved and the edge piece is not
in place in this case it is up here you
might recognize this case from my
beginner method where the corner is
solved and the edge is on the top layer
another case that might occur is one
where the middle edge is somewhere in
the middle layer such as this one and
the top corner is not placed so in this
case it happens to be up here
as you can see there are many different
cases which I would like to outline in
future tutorials the main focus of this
video however will be the easier cases
where the corner and the edge are both
in the top layer and they are separate
what we're doing in the beginner method
is we first place the bottom white
corners in these four positions and then
we place the middle edge pieces this
wastes moves and time but it is easier
for beginners to understand many of the
rules for the beginner methods such as
corner placement do apply to f2l we want
to get the white corners in the top
layer just like this one and we want
them to have white stickers on the side
this one needs to be fixed before we
place it down once it has the white
sticker on the side you look at the
other color on the side with it which is
green match it up up towards you back
down do the same with this one now as
you'll see this one's on the right side
has the white sticker facing the right
so you bring right clockwise or up top
clockwise or towards you and right
counterclockwise and what that does is
it places those two pieces down now to
fix a piece what I taught you in the
beginner method was to put it above an
empty spot and then do right clockwise
up twice and right counterclockwise and
that piece is fixed but you don't have
to always turn the top face twice in
other words you could turn this up like
that now you'll see that messes up the
cross you could turn it out of the way
and bring it back down that's another
way to fix a piece and then you can
match it up bring it up towards you back
down fix this one put it above an empty
spot
and then you could do the same thing
right
twice match it up and then you have that
place now what you might not realize
when you bring this piece down here
you're also bringing the piece that's
opposite it so when I place this corner
piece down here it's going to bring this
piece with it whatever color is on top
of this piece is going to match up with
whatever color is on the side of the
corner piece since I have orange on the
side with the white sticker orange will
match up with this yellow sticker and as
you'll see now it's paired up with that
edge so if you can get the blue orange
piece to be opposite this corner piece
here then when you place it down it will
bring that corner along okay so
hopefully you understand a little bit
more about what I'm going to teach you
in this video for the cases I'm going to
be going over we're already going to
have the corner piece and the edge piece
in the top layer so you don't have to
worry about getting the corner piece to
the top layer however you are going to
need to make sure that the white sticker
is on the side like it is here once you
have the white sticker on the side we
look at the color on the side with white
in this case it is blue so we need to
get the blue red edge piece across from
this corner and we want the blue sticker
of the edge to be on top this has the
blue sticker on the side this has the
blue sticker on top now once it's like
that
you can basically just put it down this
is the simplest f2l case so we have the
corner here the edge there lift it up
bring them both towards us and then
bring it back down again it's right
clockwise up clockwise right
counterclockwise now as I said remember
we have the corner piece across from the
edge piece but as you'll see this edge
piece it has the red sticker on top this
is not the same as the other case I just
showed you we need to have the blue
sticker on top so if you tried to
match this up and put these two down
guess what it's not going to match up in
this next f2l case we have the red white
and blue corner so that the white
sticker is on the side the blue is on
the side with white on the edge piece
the red blue edge piece we have blue on
top so as you'll notice these two pieces
are properly oriented meaning this one
has the blue sticker on the side this
one has the blue on top that's good it's
just that they are not positioned
correctly meaning this edge piece needs
to be over here if it wants to join up
with this corner piece so if we can get
this piece over here we can then join
them up by doing the simplest f2l case
how do we do that well we can do it to
one of two ways so we can either hide
the edge piece and rotate the corner or
we can hide the corner and rotate the
edge piece I prefer to hide the corner
and rotate the edge piece so what you do
to hide the corner you turn the right
face counterclockwise when you do that
you have to make sure you're not lifting
up any f2l cases that have been
previously solved and we are so we don't
want to hide it
right here if we hide it here by turning
this face clockwise we can now hide it
here it will be lifting up these two
pieces so it doesn't really matter so to
hide it again we turn the right face
counterclockwise we can now rotate this
piece freely so we turn the up face
clockwise to get it over there now since
we messed up the cross when we hid this
piece we then rotate the right face
clockwise to bring it back up
now you'll see these pieces are
positioned opposite each other so we can
now use the simplest f2l case so we
match up the blue sticker with the blue
side white is facing the right so we use
right clockwise up clockwise and right
counterclockwise alright in this case I
have the red white and blue corner here
the white sticker is on the up face so
we're going to have to flip this corner
in order to join it to the edge piece
the edge piece the blue red edge piece
has the blue sticker on the up face so
for the corner that means we want to get
the blue sticker on the side with white
we want to flip it like that however it
you can't just do that because it messes
up the bottom as you know when you fix
this piece you need to get it above
something that hasn't been solved so
we're going to put it over here above
this piece that has not been solved so
when we flip it it's basically going to
come out something like this which is
the simplest f2l case as I showed you
before to flip it what we do is we turn
the right face this is the right face
the front face and the up face turn the
right face clockwise to flip it then we
turn the up face counterclockwise to get
these two pieces out of the way and then
we turn the right face counterclockwise
to fix the cross now that these two
pieces are oriented and positioned
correctly what we do on the side of this
corner piece we have the blue sticker so
we match it up just like in the beginner
method match it up and then when you
bring this piece this corner piece down
it's going to bring down the edge piece
also so to match it and bring it down
right clockwise up clockwise and right
counterclockwise and there you go you
have now joined those two pieces
together in the bottom layers in this
case we again have the red white and
blue corner so that it has the white
sticker on the top face and the blue and
red edge is over here and it has the
blue on the top so you might think that
this is similar to the last case where
we could just kind of flip the piece in
order to get it across from this one but
you can't really do that in this case if
you flip it over here it will have blue
on the side with white however it's next
to the piece and that's no good if you
flip it counterclockwise over here it
will have red on the side with white and
you know that you can't join up red with
blue as I showed you before so what
we're going to have to do in this case
is a new technique and that's going to
be hiding the edge piece in the middle
layer so that we can rotate this corner
piece around and join it up with it now
when you're looking at this corner piece
you'll see that red is on the left and
blue is on the right so when you hide
this piece by twisting it either
counterclockwise for
clockwise you have to make sure it has
the same color arrangement red on the
left blue on the right if you flip it
this way it has blue on the left and red
on the right that's not the same so when
you go to rotate this piece around it
won't join so we need to actually rotate
this piece clockwise when you do that
you mess up this f2l pair you can't do
that so what you do is you just rotate
the top face until you have an empty
spot in front of this edge piece so now
you can rotate this piece clockwise now
looking at this piece you'll see red is
on the left and blue is on the right so
let me just go back I have them set up
like that I have an empty spot I rotate
the piece clockwise now when you rotate
the piece around look at that it joins
up with it however when you hid the
piece you messed up the cross so now we
have to fix it by turning this face
counterclockwise and now we have these
two pieces joined in the top face now to
put them down into their correct spot
you're going to look at the color that's
on the side with white in this case it's
red so we're going to be lifting the red
face and you want to lift it towards the
blue face now when I say lift it towards
I'm talking about the white sticker on
the bottom so here's the red face we
want to live
lift the white stickers towards the blue
face just like that so we're going to
turn this face clockwise just like that
that way when you rotate this around it
will join up with this cross piece and
then we could just put everything down
these next two cases that I'm going to
show you are solved in pretty much the
same exact way they only differ because
of the position of this edge piece here
as you'll see on the side of the corner
piece we have blue and white on the edge
piece we have blue on the side and red
on top okay so what do we need to do in
order to join these two pieces well as I
showed you when I shows you the simplest
f2l case when you could just bring this
down if blue is on the side then you
want blue on
top of the edge piece but this has read
so as I showed you before if you try to
bring this down the edge piece would be
flipped okay so they both have the same
orientation the edge piece has red on
top and so it is a corner piece blue on
the side so it is the corner piece what
does that mean it means that if you hid
this corner piece down in the bottom
layer you turned the edge piece all the
way around into this position and then
you brought the corner piece back you
could join the two pieces up all right
so let's hide this corner piece when you
hide a corner piece you turn it down by
turning the right face counterclockwise
and you're going to be lifting up
anything that's in this position here so
right face counterclockwise turn the up
face twice and now you'll see that edge
piece is positioned here and when we fix
the cross and bring this at the corner
piece back up by turning the right face
clockwise you'll see these two pieces
have now joined up so let's do the same
exact thing with the other one okay
since the edge piece is over here when
we bring this down make sure there's
nothing here in this position bring it
down turn this edge piece into this
position we don't need to turn twice
this time and then we bring the corner
piece back up alright so that's pretty
simple now all we need to do is to put
these two pieces down in their proper
location okay so you guys should know by
now how to put these two pieces that are
already joined in the top layer down
into their proper position whatever
color is on the side of these two pieces
that is the face you will be lifting and
you're going to be lifting it towards
whatever color is on top lifting a blue
side towards the red face blue side
towards the red face when you do that
though you'll split up these two pieces
so just make sure they're out of the way
on the side over here okay so now you
could lift the blue side towards the red
side by taking this white piece and
putting it towards the red side now you
can flip this around join it and then
bring it back down do the same thing for
the other one
so we need to lift the blue towards the
red so this needs to be out of the way
now you could do it lift it up
join it and then bring it back down I
hope that you all enjoyed this tutorial
where I covered some of the most basic
f2l cases in which the corner and the
edge are separated on the top layer we
learned about the simplest f2l case
which is always nice to get we can kind
of just bring those two pieces down we
also learned about hiding corner pieces
so that we can position the edge piece
and then we could bring the two pieces
down together you might also have to
hide the edge piece in order to join the
corner to it and then we could position
these two pieces in their correct spot
whenever you have two pieces which have
the same color on the side and the same
color on top we can hide the corner flip
around the edge join them and then we
could place them down these new
techniques should help you better
understand the methods for placing
corners and edges down together and
allow you to become faster with practice
keep in mind my f2l cases were involving
the right face but you may get a mirror
image of any of the situations I covered
please let me know what you thought of
the tutorial by leaving a comment and
rating this video and if you enjoy this
video please subscribe so you'll be
notified when I release future videos
thank you very much for watching